this turned to a more contentious issue
Harry and Megan I don't like to keep
talking about these two but for some
reason they always pop up I don't really
I find them very irritating but uh today
it's reported they're Furious because
their children aren't she and Lily bad
to be denied Royal titles this is
because Harry is no longer a working
Royal and knows uh the mother Megan what
do you think of this Alex I mean it's
completely rubbish of course I mean the
idea that the Young art chick I think
it's three year old it is going to the
nursery in Los Angeles and saying this
is awful I can't go I'm only a prince
I'm not his Royal Highness it's
ludicrous but don't they what having
said that yeah I'm just a wee bit
suspicious you see but you're always on
Megan's back and I read today well
actually and his well I don't really
bother both of them but you know I read
that they are objecting furiously Etc
I'm kind of suspicious I'm not sure that
you know ideally expressed in the
southern I know that they're objective
although we do know we do know from the
Oprah interview that they were Furious
in that about this potential issue of
the titles
my view is we had the debate about the
uniform I thought if Andrew is going to
be allowed to wear one at one event
Harry should be glad to wear his however
on the titles you can't have your Royal
cake and eat it can you Isabel I mean if
you leave Britain and Royal Duty then
your kids don't get to be hrh sorry I
think they're extremely lucky that their
children are going to be prince and
princess I was quite surprised to read
that and I don't know whether that's
because you can't take that away is it
impossible to take it away but I think
that they should be extremely grateful
that they've got that and just baby
you're groaning why are you guys are so
boring I just really don't care I think
they've gone off and they're living
quite happily I don't think they care at
all about this title nonsense
literally told Oprah Winfrey
California they're having a really nice
time she's looking really fit my essay
she's looking probably the best she's
ever looked that much
wild just how nice she looks I don't
think they care I think that we you know
maybe if it's something to do with
getting Royal protection and I still
think we should pay for that because
they are really you know open to being
harmed let's turn from two people who've
been spectacularly classed Less in the
last couple of years to someone who I
think
not YouTube you've got a wobble tonight
but we'll get you back on track
um let's talk to someone who I think is
the epitome of class who just announced
his retirement from tennis Roger Federer
greatest of all time Alex we'll have to
say under money obviously of course
but in terms of meal players I mean a
good argument for the Williams sisters
as female players but as male players
Federal yeah I mean in fact I was
fortunate enough to watch him Wimbledon
twice and the backhand is just a thing
of beauty but also his whole demeanor I
just love it I like the way he is we
look at someone like curios screaming
and ranting and shouting
well yeah look they're good to watch the
bad boys don't they like macaroni stuff
there's something about Federer which is
the epitome of class I think he's a
really good role model and maybe that's
a bit boring I don't know but you know
they've got this huge charitable
Foundation don't they they they he
doesn't do any of the theatrics any of
the ridiculous faces any of the
attention seeking he just plays tennis
brilliantly and that's his job it was a
very nice tribute to him from Rafa Nadal
his great rival wishing him all the very
best of retirement you only thought
[Laughter]
Alexander are you going to the funeral
on Monday or well I haven't received an
invitation if I if I if I get one I'll
go but although to be fair that I'm I
was at the services in jails and so and
uh you know so that I was able to pay my
respects there underlying all this when
we get back to relative normality on
Tuesday we're facing this unbelievable
economic crisis quasi-quarter Chancellor
is reported to what one of the first
things that he does to solve this
problem is to remove caps on Bankers
bonuses I gotta say when I read that I
was like are you reading the room if you
think that people in this country right
now quasi-quarting the one thing they
want the cost of living Armageddon is
let's give Bankers more money is a rich
guy the previous two chancellors were
richer than him right he's the poorest
Chancellor of the last three
I mean because you know he's obviously
favoring
part of the mindset of a banker look I
know him really well that is not how he
thinks this is about
setting out why don't you go out in the
street Isabelle if you're going to about
to start defending this go out in the
street and ask the first hundred people
you meet should bankers get a new
uncapped bonus as part of our way of
tackling the cost of living Christ I
wouldn't be setting policy According to
some Vox pop on the street in the queue
it's just having your ear slightly to
the ground isn't it I mean it's just
being a bit aware like they get paid at
right now it's 200 of their base pay
that's their bonus
I don't care
so they're children going to school at
the moment who can't qualify for free
School meals there's worried things
worry on Monday that when the schools
close children will go hungry because
they can't get their free schools
he is and the other thing I mean we've
had two things in this government so far
under Liz trust one is that the bankers
will have uncapped bonuses so they're
going to get richer right so you want
you want Bankers to be richer as the
people actually get poorer that's fine
those two things are not and secondly
energy companies should have no windfall
tax because why should their profits be
stemmed as people literally can't hear
you know what appears I've got really
bad news for you this is just the
beginning of what this government is
going to do you watch they are going to
do are you saying that proudly they
won't last yeah because right exactly I
mean look I'm an oil Economist by
profession who worked for a bank you
should definitely not uncap Bankers
bonuses and should definitely have a
windfall tax well well give you the
serious economic reason that one factor
not the only one but one factor behind
the crash of 2019 was risk taking in the
financial statement risk no no yes it
was which is
bonuses that's why it was brought
invisible rich people right now don't
need to get richer they don't that's not
the priority yeah the priority of food
banks and kids who can't afford their
School meals because they're going to
make 10 million or 20 minutes
creation and a rising tide lifts all
boots well this truss is going to cut
all the taxes apparently good it's not
going to work is it well I tell you what
hammering people on tax doesn't create
more Revenue
do you realize that if they carry on
with this attitude I think they are
going to get one of the mother of all
shellackings at the election I agree I
agree but why would you encourage it
because it isn't about winning the
election it's about doing the right
thing Isabel not only they know what the
Africa
and I can tell you the laugher card does
not apply to Bankers bonuses we're
talking about income taxes what we were
talking about an impossibly cut income
tax right now I'm not I'm not cutting in
context right now but what taxes will
she cut I imagine that they will go down
the route of that later on they will
probably cut top rate of tax because it
doesn't actually generate anything
you know what they should do she keeps I
don't know
who's pretending to be the new Maggie
Thatcher she 'd go and study what Maggie
Thatcher did when she came to power she
inherited a very bad economy and she put
up some taxation tax
on all companies and then when she
stabilizes the economy then she cut
income tax and other taxes that's what
the great heroine of the conservative
party did this person doesn't seem to
know our history anyway no thank you to
my pack great to see you all such reform
I appreciate it